welcome to gamespot of Thrones I'm Lucy
James joined of course by Kate gray
hello and Dave Jewett hey welcome to our
weekly Westerosi show where we talk
about everything about Westeros Essos
and everything in between this week
we'll be talking about season 6 episode
3 oath breaker so if you haven't seen it
consider this your spoiler warning and
if you have seen it then let's get
started so let's start the show as we do
every week by giving a brief recap of
what happened on the episodes of Kate
can you kick things off with esos yes I
can so we're not particularly keen on
terraces bits she keeps saying I'm
tenaris have you kind of not heard of me
and everyone goes hurt we have but we
don't really care at the moment she's
doing that in a vase Dothrak she's
quoting all her fancy titles and the
dosh killeen are unimpressed we also
learned viruses methods we know that
he's very good at getting secrets out of
people but we don't really know how
turns out it's a mixture of intimidation
threats and money it would have guessed
we also see Tyrion this is probably one
of my favorite bits in the episode
trying to chaperone a really awkward
date but we do find out that's
interrupted by some news that they
figured out who's paying off the sons of
the harpy it's the Masters from a stupid
young Kai and volantis shock big
surprise for us huge surprise the people
that Daenerys pissed off I'm very happy
who knew but then we got to Aria
training with the wife which is getting
more exciting she's come along a long
way in just three episodes she's now
basically a badass master at hitting
people with a stick when she can't see
and she does have this mini scene with
the wave where she sort of going who are
you and this time she actually says who
she used to be which we're not used to
seeing she normally says I'm no one but
this time she goes I used to be artistic
and the wave whips her every time she
lies which is I thought they were going
to reveal some secret through that but
they didn't they do talk about the Hound
a lot though she sort of says he was on
your list and she goes the hound and
she's like oh that's but you killed him
and our egos yes I took him off the list
and you're like oh it's gonna happen
then maybe we're gonna see the hand
returning and we see I are in the Hound
being best
ends again but then we've says that
can't be everyone you want to kill the
list that Aria has only three names
Cersei Walder Frey and Gregor Clegane at
the moment I can't be everyone you want
to kill says the way fan our egos which
name would you like a girl to speak so
she's turned into jack and her girl
basically she's going off someone if you
want we don't get to hear who the wife
wants to kill but we do see her given a
bit of a [ __ ] she look to Jack and so
maybe that's it or maybe it's something
else entirely and find me Jack and then
goes oh are you have this mysterious
water if a girl is truly no one she has
nothing to fear so Aria takes a sip
closes her eyes for ages and then she
gets her sight back yeah anally
no one heading south then on the ship to
old town Sam dropped the bomb that
Gilley will not be welcomed with him at
the Citadel and that he's actually
dropping her off with his family who I
don't know why he's trying to talk to
him up as to being a good family because
at least in the books they send him off
to the wall because they thought he was
a complete just fail human being so I
don't know he says he's doing a ghillie
safety and Gilly says oh but you know
you said would always be together and
but you're the father of my child which
is a lot better than the actual reality
of who though the father of that child
is and then in King's Landing so we see
my stack I burn has taken over viruses
little birds by bribing them with plums
which is just just like candy plums
that's obviously some reference to virus
and then he has no testes there's also
so he's making a spy network for Cersei
I don't really get why he likes Cersei
so much maybe because she's the only
person who lets him do his weird
experiments yeah but then the show I've
noticed his totally skipped calling the
mountain the reanimated mountain Sir
Robert strong they've just straight-up
gone with this is so Gregor he's back
now they dropped some hints about
Clegane Bowl about who the mountains
ultimate fight will be against but we'll
talk more about that later I love the
maester pycelle seems to have the only
natural reaction to seeing the mountain
there's a small council meeting the
mountain comes up just as maester
pycelle chat and some [ __ ] about him ah
and mr. pycelle well I for one think it
will be in our best interest to have the
beast district uh we get more of sort of
the Lannisters V everyone else in this
scene as well you get Olenna Tyrell and
Kevin Lannister sort of joining ranks
and just being against Jaime Cersei and
Gregor I like the fact that the dawn
subplot is ticking along without
necessarily having to be on screen yeah
they're just like stuff happening and
Dawn here we know and then we head to
the scepter bail or where Tommen's
backbone or whatever you had leftover
just completely disintegrates and the
poor little boy
just gets manipulated by the high
Sparrow so much good in all of us the
best we can do is to help each other
bring it out well we're talking about
the fight sequence we get to see young
Ned and Howland Reed face off against
Sir Arthur Dayne the sword of the
morning and get overseas badass dual
wielding slight change to the story we
always thought the story was that Ned
killed ser Arthur Dayne one-on-one but
turns out the Howland Reed actually
stabbed him in the back which is quite
interesting and then of course just as
we're about to see what's in the tower
so Dave the north well John wakes up and
is understandably a little confused
little scared he last thing you
remembered was being stabbed one through
the heart by bloody alley and I think I
think Davos summed it up best when he
said you were dead and no you're not
that's completely [ __ ] mad seems to
me I can only imagine how it seems to
you when he exits his room into the
courtyard of Castle black he's met by
the few loyal members of the Nights
Watch and the wildlings who now
apparently revere him some kind of God
the man who came back from the dead
although Thalman Giantsbane isn't
convinced he's a God as he says a God
wouldn't have a pecker that small though
to be fair told Jon Snow he was dead and
is pretty cold up there so there may
have been some shrinkage so you know cut
a guy break he's been through a lot
after we get through the rest of the
episode we come back to the wall and we
see some justice being rightfully dished
out to the full traitorous man that
still around Alice a thorn as defined as
every he wouldn't change it feel good if
he said like he thought he was doing the
right thing yeah no I'm not I am so
defending but like it's the same with
John right he thought they were doing
the right there yeah although hello
John's didn't equate to murder and let
me see Olly just hanging out just
looking vengeful as ever and looking a
bit like james from james the giant
peach but there were the swing of
Longclaw shot goes the rope they all
fall come tumbling down and they just
death by strangulation and what's
interesting about that scene is we've
just heard Jon Snow be night
what'swhat's cut what comes after death
and he's like nothing he knows these
guys going off into nothing hmm so he
hesitates for a bit with any you know
does it anyway then after they all come
tumbling down here he palms off his
robes to her too old Delores ed
basically gives him the mantle of Lord
Commander and then he just drops the
mike walks away
now what you sended
so a lot seemed to happen in last
night's episode even though sometimes it
felt a little bit padded a little bit
like I'll get on with a good bit um but
Kate what was your kind of like pinnacle
favorite moment so for me it was when
the umbers turn up at a Ramsay's house
and they go hey Ramsey we're here to be
your friend Ken Ramsey come out and play
and Ramses like okay what do you have
and he goes well we've got a gift and
last week we correctly predicted that
gift would be Rickon Stark we didn't
actually figure out that it would also
be a ship would come along with him and
also that shaggy dog or what's left of
shaggy dog would come along as proof
that recon is indeed a stark so that was
quite sad but there were a lot of
interesting moments in that clip that
make me think maybe there's more than it
seems so first of all the humble guy
refuses to swear an oath I'm looking
your [ __ ] hand traditionally a banner
man kneels before his Lord not doing
that either hmm he swears in every other
way he does we're quite a lot um and
he's quite convincing with his reasons
he's like oh why would you trust me
anymore if I swore an oath there's been
plenty of that and it hasn't worked out
for most people your dad swore an oath
and they killed everyone so you know if
I swear an oath it means nothing so I'm
not going to I'm not kissing your hand
and I completely agree with him that
would be gross I wouldn't kiss any part
of Ramsey who knows where he's been
flown well well everywhere um but here's
the idea maybe he doesn't want to swear
an oath because it would be a lie oh and
then he would become the oath breaker in
the title of the episode although he
hasn't obviously done that yet I am the
the idea here is that he's swearing
loyalty to the Bolton's but he doesn't
mean it he saw us wearing to them it's
like doing everything apart from signing
the papers yeah he's like you can trust
me why wouldn't you trust me i hate the
wildlings first of all saying the a at
the wildlings
doesn't really seem like a great
motivation to to ally with a guy who's
so untrustworthy he killed his own dad
there's a lot of dad killing obviously
but either their dads are [ __ ] all
there are souls or both so you know
that's not really I wouldn't want to
ally with the guy that you know mad dog
insane so you know first of all there's
that and secondly reckon doesn't really
react to the fact that his beloved
direwolf's head is dumped on the table
and you'd think if it was truly shaggy
dog he'd be a bit sad maybe he's just a
bad actor but maybe he does been dead
for ages and he watched a happen maybe
but still it would be enough saying site
if your mom's head was rolled out on the
table you wouldn't be like and seen it
what he bought concerned about being
flayed or having a sausage topped offers
Oh reek did yeah he's already been
referred to as recon online and I were
you getting real nervous about that is a
kid yeah I know but I mean the thing
about shaggy dog is it's a part of me
wants to believe that it's not shaggy
dog yeah how big would a direwolf
actually be is at the right size it's
probably sure you don't it was only a
very brief view of the wolf's head hmm
we don't know what shaggy dog looks like
I don't remember what shaggy dog looks
like probably similar to the rest yeah
but that might not be him we haven't
seen him in ages so there's no proof
really you know getting after a wolf's
head isn't properly proof so I'm keen
for the umbers to literally stab Ramsey
in the back and then use the the
presence of the stark boy to reinstate
the stocks at least you know in
Winterfell and see where they go from
there but what's interesting is though
even if even if wildlings are their
biggest concern and he didn't he mention
that Jon Snow like is definitely up
there yes and yet he didn't take Rick on
to John he just decided to take him
straight to Ramsey if he if he knows
because he knows that John met the wild
things through mm-hmm so to him someone
he's fought wardens on his life yeah he
considers his home now under threat I
suppose the one person he could get men
from be Ramsey who's now
yeah but do you think maybe he's trying
to get the men from ramsey or do you
think he's actually a lying with Ramsey
no I definitely think it's just an act
of desperation he needs Ramsey's men
yeah and Rick on his in trouble yeah
also our IP tracker doc your father was
a my beloved father the water father was
a good and that's why you killed him are
you seems to have gone full Matt Murdock
in this episode which I'm super happy
about Dave I'm really glad that she's
like back in training the whole just
being around blind beggar girl just get
a bit tedious because you know she
deserves better than that exactly she's
just getting whipped and punched for for
nothing so the way takes her back we get
to see her awesome training montage
which was about his training montage I
think the series has ever got
you
then after her montage jacket and the
wave and see the trainings coming well
she source almost considered like a no
one hmm and Jackie makes a drink from
the well that we've seen is like we've
been led to believe it's poison because
she feeds it to that young girl to like
end her suffering she dies and Jack and
says true no one has nothing to fear she
takes a little sippy sip gets her eyes
back mm-hmm and now it seems to me at
least that she's she's no one now but
this has been we've been leading up to
this for so long what do you think is
next for area I kind of hope she
develops more of her senses she did that
in the book it wasn't just about
fighting it was about hearing and
smelling and feeling things without
being able to see a bit more daredevil
than it actually is entered of that in
in the montage because she's smelling
yeah boys no sure eating the bottle yeah
one who had an X on it yes I'm guessing
she's making poison through feel and
smell a little vibe I was getting at
least so the one thing that I'm thinking
about is that is she truly no one
because no one is meant to have no
personal belongings but she threw needle
if he actually hit me decision she's
hidden needle so is she holding on to
that and she is she actually really no
one and the jack and her God doesn't
know what does Jack and hung gaan know
that she's done that and she's just
gonna get punished for it later I still
think I think we mentioned this in the
last episode that she's kind of trying
to manipulate the the whole Faceless Men
thing to what she wants rather than what
they want her to want yeah and whether
that's going to end like you say in her
being punished because they know
seemingly everything or whether she's
actually going to come out of it the
other side and use it to her advantage
whatever that may be mmm it's going to
be interesting to find out I don't know
what I expected from tariff joy and
mirth I mean a medley more than that but
you know as always watching you I was
thinking mmm this is going to cleanly
this is going this is ticking along too
nicely I'm gonna cut stuff off and they
did like right as it got good but there
are a lot of interesting talking points
from that see
mean so let's talk a little bit about
net because as [ __ ] this story as far as
we've known is that Ned bested Sir
Arthur Dayne who's the greatest
swordsman at the Seven Kingdoms at the
time Ned managed to beat him like in
sword fighting and so when brian says
you know like he's much better than my
father and then Howland Reed just comes
out of nowhere I think his Ned's I don't
think Ned lied to be like peacocking
about it he lied for a reason maybe to
protect Howland Reed or even Arthur
Dayne because he was the greatest sword
hmm and you know that's not the good way
to die I guess it's also it's not very
surest it's not it's no dishonorable
four nights I guess yeah we've always
known Ned as a very honorable person so
he could have been protecting both the
honor of the stabbed and the stabby hmm
or maybe Howland Reed was just being
like us and just being just like get up
there already stop sword fighting just
go go on abundance Howlin reaches
represents the fan base yes um so i
thought i had like weird feelings about
Ned after seeing nine to be honest but
I'm sure they'll and I asked him branded
to UM but there are loads of really good
theories about bran first of all that he
because he can see into the past and
have these green seeing visions that he
might be the old man and tree he might
be the three-eyed Raven which i think is
quite interesting because you never
actually see the olds the old guy move
from the waist down but there's an
interesting theory going around that
that is old bran and that he's using his
green seeing to go back in time and tell
young bran not to basically stay in too
long and get stuck in the tree but yes
is what happened so what if that goes
wrong and then there's a third version
of brand that comes out right the
undergoes you guys so fit like skeleton
daisy old brown on the floor
and he's like the hell's going on here
so speaking of time travel paradoxes cuz
that's where I'm going um i right
basically you can get all time travel e
and I normally hate that I really
honestly I hate time travel as a plot
device this is interesting though it's
sort of like it's a thing called a
stable time loop where you don't know
what comes first chicken or egg so Brian
if he can use his visions to go back in
time we know that so like you know the
scene where he he says father and he
looks around and he's like oh was it the
wind or can Brian actually like talk to
people through these his visions his
dreams so if he can do that what if he
went back in time in a vision and he
spoke to King eres Mad King eres so the
reason basically the all of the events
of Game of Thrones as we know a
happening is because mad king air is
burned Rick on and brandon stark alive
so thats brands grandfather and his
uncle and that's what sparked off like
Robert's rebellion like Rhaegar Liana
that whole thing start from like that
one scenario so wife bran went back in
time and was like talking to king air is
trying to get him to stop doing that but
because King heiress is mad he like just
thinks it's voices in ten just burns
them so what if bran like keeps going
back in time to try and fix things and
he actually ends up making it worse what
I'm saying is what if all of Game of
Thrones is brands fault yeah yeah Jesus
he's like Marty McFly this whole thing
this is going back messing things up
yeah the stuff in the books where Brown
goes to visit his dad like through the
weirwood tree and he talks to him and
Ned will react we've seen more of this
in the show which kind of hints the
brand has like stronger power than we
thought he did but you guys think the
time travel at least at this point is a
cop-out it seems a bit clumsy yeah you
of being able to talk to the pastor of
the travel mmm that seems a little
cleaner but then you get to the whole
thing my paradoxes I think I mean the
stable timely means that like the event
in the past happened and because that's
happened the event in the future happens
that allows you to go in the past
chicken and egg you don't know which is
the thing that started yeah so he thinks
he's going back to stop his grandfather
being burned when actually he's the
cause yeah so that's why it happens and
if he didn't go it wouldn't happen but
he has to go because he already did so
yeah so like he's got neither but burns
and then he tries to go back and change
it yeah in doing so he calls his car and
he goes in this yeah this is like I just
find this theory really really
interesting I mean of all the weird
things that game of thrones is
introduced I wouldn't put it past them
to have something like this mmm like I
said it needs to be something so like
speaking as the pass Robin yeah have
like new if it does happen though I kind
of want him to go to every single huge
event in Game of Thrones like he goes to
Rhaegar at the the Paranal Tony oh and
he goes don't think Lyanna stark is hot
and he goes lianna stop she is hot she
is real hard and you're like brand new
do you think he's actually gone back in
time to tell his old self not to climb
the tower yeah and then that was
actually the sender the turned round and
looked at yeah exactly basically
everything in France wall we all do that
I estoy line has been kind of like one
of my favorites this series just it
keeps it goes just like every episode
like something great in happens and I'm
really enjoying where it's going Dave's
just throwing me this absolute curveball
of a fan theory that I am I love Dave
take away so there was a hint at a game
ball at this episode Jamie Jamie
mentions the trial by combat including
earth mountain and we've always thought
that the trial by combat would be the
mountain versus the hound but there was
a slight variant on that theory that I
found on the reddit by a redditor named
salted pork delicious excellent name and
in their post they say I'm pretty sure
we'll see Arya Stark as sandicor gained
versus Gregor Clegane in the game Bowl
2016 so I guess that the theory is that
now she's no one she will take the face
of the hound mmmn fight the mountain but
if you think about it like that be hell
of a fight like the mountains weakness
with the one fight we've seen him almost
lose ya was against the Viper
was because he couldn't keep up with the
Vipers speed I was waiting fast also
he's wearing like loads of heavy hot
arman in like 30 degrees sun yeah which
he now can no longer take off and I got
n his weakness was fighting against
someone who's very fast area pretty damn
speed she is nifty husband xterra is up
to oh yeah max level decks like we've
seen her fight with needle in the past
we've seen her most recently fighting
with the staff Nick and she small so
she'd get around that but do we think
this theory could happen I mean it's not
it's not actually mentioned if the
faceless men can change size as well i
was gonna say cuz like an ayah size tiny
man sorry my own tubby all of its ok
would it work that's the thing if we
find out that the faceless man could
also change size are you some sort of
glamour to do that as well hmmm theory
could hold water but I think I think
that's the main thing that could blow
all apart I was going to say the travel
time I mean we've already seen travel
time isn't really too important because
we've seen people zip from the wall to
Pike island and it's that one Stannis
and Davis went two Bravo yeah yeah but
are you at the moment is in Braavos and
I don't know how long it takes to get
from there to King's Landing but she's
not even considering that at the moment
so we'd have to see some pretty fast
development for her to go from I'm
learning how to hit people with a stick
to I'm gonna dress up as the guy I
killed that one time and fight I also
think though the the gravedigger theory
at least at this point definitely more
water and yeah someone's seen like
someone who could be the hound but also
the hounds horse that's the thing like
if if like it's a big if if faceless man
can change size and if area does turn
into the Hound a disguise of the hound
then I mean people are still seeing the
hound mmm maybe someone else could have
been the hound yeah just what can I give
you two could just be a mistake like I'm
not sure this theory is gonna happen but
my god is an interesting one how did
they get his face they've got a lot
faces yeah but its journey do you got
face do you have to cut it off oh you've
seen jackin i think in one of the
trailers zzz maybe she did that off
camera just took it put it
I back yeah bird one guy's face along
Bucky and you're done yeah also well
what's the next episode called was that
book of strange strange is one of the
seven gods yeah so that would kind of
tie in with the faith no who's the other
half of that trial by combat and also I
might be wrong here what's what's the
hounds horse called does i think i read
it was called stranger that could be
wrong but if that's right that's too
quickly and maybe you can read so it's
got a book time now as always for death
of the week i have a clear favorite this
week just because it gave me feelings
and thoughts and made me distrust Ned
Stark which I never thought would happen
in that ser Arthur Dayne sort of the
morning best best blade in the Seven
Kingdoms stabbed in the back by Howland
Reed so sad he deserved better although
he was using two swords and he wasn't
meant to use tony was keeping a woman in
a tower we can still will also go see
though we don't know that yet we sort of
know that yet but nope I think I don't
know what like I just thought everything
about that choreography was amazing it
was his like well sure people against
two blades I was awesome yeah um but
also i got Ned why did you lie why would
you lie I mean we don't know yeah many
reasons why he would lie but it still
kind of doesn't lie a lot ah Rachel good
night of the great point okay who's a
death of the week I mean that won't bat
many to choose from well well my death
of the week is and I think a lot of
people will agree with me on this one
Ollie [ __ ] holly bloody that's all I've
written shaking Lee the God not see us
all she's written so we see him being
hanged with the rest of the traitorous
Nights Watch members and we see them
turn all blue and puffy with you know
strangulation and its really interesting
like you know that scene where Joffrey
dies and his face gets disgusting
they're really good at making the makeup
look kind of grotesque and they manage
to do that even though they were just
being strangled so we got to watch Ollie
answer I was the Thor internal purple
and that they're definitely dead I mean
that was a lingering shower
as well it was like yeah you even this
yes fan base even though so all of those
deaths were ok now Alistair and Ollie
were great the other two we couldn't get
less but don't know mostly Holly Holly
but Dave you've you've written down a
different death my death of the week was
the death of Tommen's backbone he was it
alive in the first place had a hint of
it was like hanging on for dear life
like the heart monitors beep beep when
he was standing up to the high Sparrow
he's gay yeah he had tears in his eyes
and you know he was angry he was
utilizing the anger and then the high
Sparrow is just lame come sit down have
you thought I'd take a seat with me God
and then and then it just flat line and
tommy was like oh don't tell me all
about this it's common but he is my
money my favorite thing about is that he
used Tommen's weakness his love for his
mother yeah he's ID like oh wait oh that
your mother's got this mad chick inside
when she said okay before I love it was
like Tommen man like she was covered in
poop narrated to the street you know
what fight for your mama fight for your
wife as well Tommy oh yeah for someone
he has actually kind of forgot about her
like we all have a little bit sorry we
still love you Madhuri all right we're
gonna have a separate spoiler warning
here because now we're going to talk
about the next episode which is book of
a stranger so if you haven't seen the
promo for season 6 episode 4 it was the
end of last night's episode if you
haven't seen it if for some reason you
clicked away or turn the channel what
you're doing it's like leaving a Marvel
movie before the end credits sequence
but we're talk about that now I'm
possible hints about what might be
coming so we haven't seen it turn away
now all right Dave trying to kick things
off with Sansa arriving at the ball this
has to be so frustrating it's
frustrating to watch okay admittedly yes
but imagine you've gone all this way
like you've escaped Ramsay to go to the
wall to find your brother and he's like
sorry love you just missed him he's just
like fresh tracks in the snow yeah but
that's like instead of following those
I'm guessing this could the silver
lining of this could be the start of a
super team up between Sansa and Davos a
dream team since then I'll suck at
Castle black if the if the wildlings
don't go with John hmm then chances are
they may either go back south and
caramel there
ring but I think this could be leading
up to the battle scene that we saw
outside winds phantom the trailers hmm
so we see Ramsay the heaven army mm-hmm
which makes sense now because like he's
he's now pledged himself to help against
the wildlings yeah he secured the umbers
the man delays and the car start exactly
especially after the gift of recon recon
so they could now be heading north to
fight the wildlings but that wildlings
could also be moving south to find John
even now think of as a god and one so
you know defend him and especially if if
Sansa turns up explains to Davos that
help me Ramsey's hunting me he was awful
all these horrible things he did to me
he might also be able to like get all
the men from Castle black and all the
wildlings on his side much south the
fight Ramsay maybe they'll meet the
middle so as frustrating as this is
gonna be for them just arriving as
John's left yeah the silver lining is
maybe this is a pretty domestic bowl so
you just think that it's it sucks
they've just missed each other but it
gives time for San sir and Davos to make
their dream team onions and lemon cakes
for it together forever buddy caught me
if you've always on it and then they'll
go down a little bit John will just be
chillin being I don't know what to do
and they'll be like well it's a mission
for your friend and then it all kicks
off oh yes that's why I'm hoping for
anyway otherwise it's just frustration
force frustrations sake yeah and Kate
Marjorie's back she's been gone for so
long but we finally got a glimpse of her
yes we did she's looking pretty worse
for wear her hair's kind of gross we see
her in her cell and she's finally being
lifted up by a guy who looks like the
high Sparrow it's a spiritual and it's
it's a symbolic thing of lifting her up
raising her up maybe she actually thinks
she's going to confess now and that's
what Circe goes and tells Elenna she
goes Marjorie's gonna confess in front
the whole city and alone and then it
goes can't let that happen for various
reasons it's embarrassing it makes the
Tyrells look bad and you know we don't
want to know what she's been up to she's
been up to things that need to stay
secret probably girls gonna have a
secrets oh yeah alone has loads and so
Alana goes yeah we can't do that and
Cersei surprising me says
I agree so buddy cop movie version 2 we
don't actually know what's gonna happen
here now Cersei looks like she's saying
I agree in that kind of smirky Cersei
way and that could either mean that she
does actually agree but only to get the
Tyrells on her side so that she can
fight the faith which is plausible or
she's saying that she's about to have
the mountain and kill everyone in the
room and then killed Marjorie I guess
also possible I've seen in previous
trailers if I were called the Tyrell
Army yessir leaves certainly mace Tyrell
in his fancy garb mm-hmm with his giant
blue helmet so this must be like part of
Circe's greater ploy to at least have
some numbers yes so somehow she's gonna
stop Marjorie confessing hopefully not
with murder because that means she won't
really have anyone on his side although
I do kind of want to see a murder sooner
or later the mountain hasn't really done
many important murders he smashed
someone's head that's about it um so we
know I think we know this er she's going
to get the Tyrells onside we don't know
how she's going to do that exactly but
it's likely manipulation and PB murder
of the high Sparrow somehow sooner or
later it's going to happen it could be
next episode and my love my favorite
character I am so glad he's back
Littlefinger's back he can see him with
dear little sweet robin and his minder
basically it just looks a little finger
is it gonna do what little finger does
best that's not accents limitedly but he
says um Santa has escaped Winterfell she
won't be safe with the Bolton's after
her which sort of sort of seems like
it's his fault that she was admittedly
with the Bolton's so maybe I want to say
that little finger feels remorse or
guilt cuz I don't think that it's
possible for him to do that but he
doesn't have that part of his brain he
does love Catelyn Stark a lot he does
love stands to stock a lot so it's
interesting to see if he's gonna catch
her like convince Robin to give his
armies because the veil is really well
protected it's real it's a great not
only is it great locate
but their armies are really strong
really well equipped and trained so if
he's going to offer the veils Army's tus
answers by way of apology for snowball
snow down whatever you want to call it
it also means that Robin will take the
fall and that he can just do what he
does best and not not get any blaming
snow get the blame but also he he wanted
to be ward in the north right that's one
yeah he was gearing up for he didn't
ultimately get it so it's a way of him
for him to easily get Ramsey out yeah
you get Sansa back maybe you sansom is
gonna like give anyone more than the
North I don't know a woman can be not
warden of the north she can be um yeah
she can be air now right cuz she's the
only one yeah but like would she give
that wardenship it's a Spanish what
would she do instead she would just take
it and banish him right give it to Davos
systems like cool guy he's used to ships
he can't be stuck up in the north he'll
be sad he's got a fingers through and
get frostbite only on one hand yeah true
so that was off breaker guys will go
over all opinions on the episode Kate uh
my overriding opinion is oh my god we
just see the Tower of joy already at
this rate we won't get to see it until
episode 5 by the sounds of it and we
waited so long so especially if we read
the books and we've been waiting for our
porcelli 20 a thought more like a
billion a billion years a billion actual
years and I just wanted to happen other
than that the episode was fine but bored
by Denarius not really much happening in
marine I'm non I'm not looking forward
to the amount of Daenerys in next week's
episode cuz there's Jorah and Daario
I've given them nicknames Bora and dari
no um I don't know I just feel like her
plot lines kind of faltering a little
bit and clave well especially after the
last episode well the ships are burning
like Google guess we're not going to
Westeros anytime soon yeah but for this
episode I mean it's the week is up so so
far but I don't think it's a bad episode
by enemy no I mean it's sort of saying
like the quality that we're far I think
the wall saved it if the
wall stuff hadn't have happened it would
have been real boring there's some
really good moments but then the bits
around those moments were kind of just
either updates to remind people of these
parts that exist or setting up for the
next episode yeah I felt like when
Tyrion was talking to me sunday and grey
worm that that was just order to justify
a Peter Dinklage being there yes I'd
like nothing mean to say so they just
gave him a little it just felt like the
gonk scene when he'd wait oh yeah it is
about khong yeah breaking Beatles yeah
again just a scene they didn't need to
exist yeah but next week we got some
badass Brienne hopefully oh yeah so make
sure to join us to talk about next
week's episode Monday's youtube.com
slash gamespot or of course gamespot com
or if you'd like this episode in an
audio format so you can listen in the
car on your commute just before you go
to bed be sure to check out gamespot of
Thrones on itunes you can follow us on
twitter i'm at least james games i'm at
how not to draw and i'm at a regular
dave and we will see you next week